german chancellor angela merkel is set
to take power away from the 16 federal
states to decide on coronavirus
restrictions
a new plan will see the central
government take over when infection
numbers
rise to a certain level germany is
battling a brutal
third wave and regional decision-making
has led to a confusing patchwork
approach
if i want to go shopping in berlin i can
do that if i get tested beforehand
here i can do that right in front of the
shopping center and
the test is for free
the testing bird goes in and out and the
shopping can begin
with these rapid tests many cities are
loosening restrictions
meanwhile in other places new covered
measures are implemented
and curfews put in place everywhere in
the country
the rules are different leading to
confusion
nobody knows anymore what the
regulations are right now
i think it's chaos especially if you
look at the different vaccination
strategies
in berlin they're very good in lower
saxony it's a disaster
it is just not working his life
are going back and forth and want to
distinguish themselves with new
proposals
but the scientists they are doing a much
better job
and they are very clear on what germany
needs right now
we look into our mobility analysis and
we see
that contacts have not been reduced as
much as during the first lockdown
and that's where we need to come back to
because we're dealing with the new
variant b117
which is spreading faster the only way
to do that is through a coherent
systematic intensive and maybe shorter
lockdown
here at the chancellor's office angela
merkel is calling for a strict
and nationwide lockdown but federal
states have the decision-making powers
in the fight against the pandemic
and these states have very different
views especially now that the election
campaign has started
amin lashed from northrend westphalia
and marcosuda from bavaria
are fighting over the cdu's candidacy
for chancellor
is the political management of the
crisis going out of hand
this is politics politicians always say
we have to make long-term decisions but
actually they're thinking of the next
election
that's why they want to avoid
uncomfortable inconvenient decisions
decisions people won't understand but
that's a mistake because in times of
crises
people want security and they are also
prepared to take responsibility
but politicians have to lead the way
straightforward covert measures that is
what people are calling for
here in germany stricter laws could now
ensure this
the political discussion continues
earlier we spoke to our chief political
correspondent melinda crane she
explained why germany's central
government will gain more power over
coronavirus restrictions
german law until now has placed
responsibility for
infectious disease control largely in
the hands of regional
authorities and there's enormous
variance
in the rate of infection across
different regions of germany
so some rural regions have rates as low
as
uh 30 cases uh per 100 000 residents
others go up to almost 300 cases per 100
000
residents so there has been a lot of
variation in the way that different
regional
authorities approach this however they
do regularly negotiate with the federal
government about what kind of
restrictions to put into place
and all agreed at the beginning of march
on a phased
plan that would see uniform restrictions
in the event of one particular
circumstance namely
infection rates over a hundred cases per
hundred thousand
residents however that has not occurred
and that's because the fact is that
there are places even including the
capital here berlin
that have uh infection rates over that
number and are still
trying to sort of sort of do a lockdown
light where there might be a light
curfew
but at the same time more testing and
shopping and that is what the federal
government now
wants to change and interestingly enough
the federal state leaders
say they're ready to go along uh because
i think there is recognition
that we need more reliability we need
binding
plans and we need clarity clarity
also for citizens to ensure that they
comply with the rules that are put into
effect
so we could see action as early as this
weekend and beginning
of next week that will change the
federal uh
infectious disease laws in order to give
the federal government
more power and many citizens wait would
say this is
long overdue